- My worst gift ever was one year,
I don't know why, Santa Claus got me a DVD
of the movie, "Big Chill."
- "Big Chill"?
- Again, I'm, like, 13 years old.
So this is a movie about,
you know, midlife crisis.
I don't know why I'm on the list
but I remember going like, "Okay."
(Kelly laughing)
"Big Chill,"
about people are trying
to have a baby and stuff.
Like I, yeah, okay.
I guess Santa thought
the soundtrack was good,
that I would like it.
I love it now that I'm in my 40s,
but, no, when you're a kid...
- That's amazing!
No, that was not
one of my best gifts.
- That's a weird gift that they
definitely weren't thinking
of you when they got it.
Like, that's a weird... (chuckling)
- I think Santa was thinking of Santa.
- [Kelly] We forgot to get,
so we just pulled something.